what's been like some of the most
favorite things you've discovered
because you you know talk every time I
Tau you you had like a period not just
with memes but we've kind of like so
many pieces of media that you kind of
just like Miss in terms of like pop
culture has there been anything you've
discovered that has been like
integrating to like now modern pop
culture that you're like damn this is
cool experiencing this for the first
time whether it be like a TV show Game
anything I have not seen a movie in 10
years isn't that wild like that can't be
true the last movie I saw was with you
in Angeles oh that was the first time
I'd been to a theater in 10 years what
yeah you must have watched only on the
airplanes and I as a theater
Maj yeah I mean but like but I don't
take that many planes right so you're
talking about like going to a theater
I'm talking about having Netflix and and
watching a movie on a Tuesday night okay
before the movie you watched with Connor
what was the last movie you watched the
one from 10 years ago oh um it was that
Batman movie that was dog [__] and
that's what turned me off ofit we the
final Nolan one
oh the ban one dark rises so bad yeah
dark KN RIS bad it was awful it was so
many plot holes and and uh I
could understand tomatoes and like I
like those I like CH it was okay it was
I like Christopher Nolan I like the two
movies those were good those were very
good I like you just think the last one
was [__] it was not only [__] it was
unwatchable
ohage I wouldn't go that far but it was
definitely out of three noan films it
was definitely the worst one and I like
all the actors in it but every single
moment it's just like PL dude it goes
the the in order it goes from best to
worst The Dark Knight The Dark Knight
Rises Batman Begins I thought thought
Batman Begins was better than RIS I
thought begins was better than Dark
Knight Rises just because Dark Knight
Rises I think had so many things going
on so what people are dumb all the
people people are from the Cincinnati
Zoo we have we have
250,000 or I mean look if you like the
movie it's fine but they should have
called it The Dark Knight DSX Machina
because anything that needed to happen
at any point to progress the movie Just
magically happened age and I can't stand
when they do that in drama it's not a
it's not like his best movie uh I don't
think literally play RPG games that's
that's all it is I am flawed that is all
it is all it is is day [__] I know I
understand where I can come across as a
hypocrite that's not what we're talking
about but uh I welcome to trash face
everyone this is the first time has ever
happened in the history of trash taste
who would have told hot takes on trash
taste but I think that yeah I saw that
in the theaters and I didn't like it and
so that was 2012 yeah that's the last
time I went to the theater that's just
like I'm never seeing a movie again I
was like I'm good but I I will say the
thing that I'm happy as a huge theater
nerd and like you know someone who
really respects drama I think we did go
through a nice golden age of Television
that I did miss out on but I'm happy
existed with your breaking bads and your
Game of Thrones you miss breaking bads I
I've seen them since right but like I'm
really glad that in in an era now where
movies I feel kind of just been rehashed
and kind of not a lot of originality
These Days TV not not there's exceptions
but TV really came into its own with
some awesome gripping narratives and I
think that's that's cool TV has gotten
really good in the past like 20 years it
was really bad from before 2008 or so
it's cuz it was like the way that they
syndicated TV shows like it had to be 25
episodes had to run for so long and and
if the network wanted to changes plot
they could just change the plot and and
so it's it's changed a lot how TV is
made yeah I I don't know I don't know if
that's true I just I'm try I'm trying to
think of like the classic TV shows but
well look at it like this yeah like
things like Seinfeld or friends or
malcol the middle most popular shows and
half we sitcoms right we were long
running TV shows and now I guess you
have more narratively driven shows as
well I guess yeah I guess like before
I'm trying to think of like some way
more shows get made now yeah yeah I mean
that's that's true um you had The
Sopranos the wire those were the ones
that broke the mold even when I was
still there they were like doing those
was like HBO only yeah they were the
only people trying to do like I guess
that makes sense yeah it's been but it's
been cool to see people really enjoy
television again that's been a missing
thing I mean I I I think the rise of
that came from just streaming platforms
so now you because because the people
are
enjoying remember it was like box set
culture where you would buy the box set
of all of the seasons of a show the
problem with TV shows before is that you
had to tune in at the TV at the regular
time it's right by the DVDs yeah yeah
and sometimes you just couldn't like do
that 10 minutes an ad you know so now
with like online streaming culture you
get you don't have to worry about if the
audience has seen previous episodes
because you can just assume they have
yeah I do miss that though like I think
the closest we used to call it water
cooler TV shows where you stand around
the water water cooler and discussed
last night's most relevant episode of De
has anyone ever done that I am
yes I would argue trash taste is that
yeah it's like like you just filmed an
episode about that about Attack on Titan
Water no no has anyone ever because I
I've always heard about
water this wouldn't be a term if people
hadn't done it don't say oh it's the
[__] elephant talk anyone who works
at an office I think has done that it's
because uh if you don't smoke back in
the day you only had the chance to get
up and stand around and like slowly fill
up your teacup no cuz in the UK it was
like the making tea talk that's we
didn't have water speaking of I brought
you guys a little taste of England I
forgot about Oh I thought somebody I I I
had met a viewer recently and they they
came to Japan and they right my
grandmother rest in peace she did not
get shot or anything but she was 99 why
do you why do you have to breakast that
died natural natural a thing that
American after PR get shot and she was
Welsh and so she's from that Village
that I can't
pronounce Lord the Rings um and so but
my favorite snack growing up was these
these uh dodgy Jammers or Jammy Dodgers
Jammy Dodgers Dodgers you got Jammy
Dodgers so I have Jammy Dodgers that's
the new packaging yeah it's the new new
packaging these wait you had these
growing up ah yeah these are these are
really good no nasty stuff we're Jammy
enough yeah so really liked you if you
had these available at the kind of the
these are the best biscuits right not
the jafa cakes not the digestives the
digestives are kind of like the the the
yeah I'll Stand the digestive these are
definitely more fancy if you had these
you kind of a bit more of a bougie
family Yeah Yeah well yeah well should
you crack it
over dog I I forgot you had one of these
I have once or twice yeah they are
really good with a tee really likes you
do need to have them with a tee but they
taste pretty good on their own I
probably should have uh I me give them
to you after the show but we started
talking about
go they all goated as you say I can't
how do you I'm not British what do you
mean opened it like I see I must say I'm
bricked up I'm
all you go man these are these are
fantastic there you go thank you very
much actually I hate raspberry so I just
I'm down bad right now oh wait here's
one in here down bad I'm down bad man I
am so down bad for a Jammy
do if you hate The Dark Night Rises and
you think that's the most awful film
what are what are films you actually
like them give give me give me give me a
give me an insight into Pete's mind of
what his tastes are actually like top
five films go
yeah all right let's go it's a really
really tough question obviously but I
would like easily first is Ghostbusters
it's my favorite movie that's a personal
classic it's a classic and it was at the
time the most expensive comedy ever made
in the history of movies which is pretty
pretty wild to think about number two is
LA Confidential a fantastic crime Noir
film that's really really great and if
you haven't seen it Guy Pierce Russell
Crow Kim
Basinger fer it didn't win the Oscar
right cuz I Titanic came out the same
year so dumb am I crazy the you're right
you're right it's it's a travesty uh
this one kind of controversial because
it's made by a horrific scumbag named
Roman palansky who is a horrible dude
but if you separate art and artist
Chinatown with Jack Nicholson one of the
finest noirs you'll ever see I happen to
prescribe to the the fact that sha Shank
Redemption is the most rewatchable movie
I I really like a great movie it's a
great movie I I haven't seen a single
person like get bored of sh Shang
Redemption no I don't think that you can
and so and then my final one to round
out it's so hard to choose just five but
the theater guy in me would probably say
12 Angry Men cuz we're going to go old
school with it which is just a nice one
setting but like that's when you were
born right I was actually um I was 10 so
I had to study that for school
I got to get another one you know if we
were I feel like it's like asking
someone their favorite game it's
impossible you got to go by genre or era
he just answered it immed he didn't mean
that he he he said ginin I think under
his he was like ginin Mass Effect I said
Mass Effect even though the third ones
like the dark yes I like the third Mass
Effect that's actually my favorite Mass
Effect God we have a real problem here
this is worse than I think the [__]
complaints about the ending were
overblown I don't know it's people were
just like complaining I still think like
obviously like from like I guess like a
critical standpoint the second one was
like the best the bridge yeah yeah but I
just liked seeing the uh send off to all
the characters so that's why the third
is my favorite I feel like did you ever
play Mass Effect Trilogy you can skip it
did you play it good job so this is just
a one-onone don't skip it all I'm going
to say is this to everybody who's played
Mass Effect you know I'm right when I
say that how excit exciting was it to
recruit the rakite queen or to make all
these choices with the Krogan all of
them to be a resource at the war table
come on that was they didn't matter
nothing none of your choices mattered in
Endo choices don't matter I think choic
is kind of overrated in my opinion in
video games it's kind of overrated you
convinced me
yeah literally lost well [__] I've
changed my mind it's like that Simpsons
meeting the guys
like just give me a linear story I don't
want to make my own choices I'm a
[__] dumbass okay you think you
should you think I should be trusted to
make the best choices in the video games
no we were literally just discussing
this in the last episode what do you
think about multiple endings in video
games yeah see I knew
I I get to role play my character player
it's the best what what's the argument
against multiple endings just shoehorned
in that's all right yeah you don't have
to do those ones yeah like I I I think
uh like I I said this in like the
previous episode where I think if you
have multiple endings it kind of like
detracts from the impact of some of the
endings you could have because you know
when you have a definitive ending if you
think of like if you can choose your own
ending for a movie would you you know um
I understand what you're saying yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely I prefer
one solid AR one artistic Vision that
the director had in mind sure and by
having multiple endings you kind of like
I I guess the storytelling like power of
that to me kind of like gets detracted
you know usually games have the a Canon
ending though right like like a true
ending yeah and so like my best example
oh we're going so old is like Chrono
Trigger which has nine different endings
or thereabouts and each one is unique
enough where you would go out of your
way to see a different outcome but you
know that there's only one true actual
ending but dude I played I played it and
I got all nine endings yeah me too and
like but I feel like a go to game yeah
and you can I think there's usually
pretty strong evidence to suggest this
is what probably
L to the actual events have you ever
like read like a choose your adventure
book or yeah remember
Goosebumps that sh watch like Banda
snatch on Netflix I still haven't got
around to that I haven't G around to
that one yeah it's the fact that I
didn't want to I didn't want to watch
something and I have to choose exactly
right exactly so how about this though
Mar play goes to space I've
seen it's a great she Adventure well one
of my favorite movies that I didn't
mention is an old comedy called clue
like the board game cludo you know it
doesn't sound like it' make for a great
movie but one of the coolest things that
it did in the theaters was depending on
which theater you went to it had one of
three different endings because like the
board game there's no real you when you
play it always comes out different I
think that's an awesome idea to have an
a random ending depending on which
theater you go to that's I thought that
was it's really great that sounds awful
you should try sounds a that's kind it
kind of sounds cool sounds like that's a
great way to get people pay to watch the
movie three times I think to me that
more sounds like a gimmick than it does
a kind of like artistic hey take my
money bro all right well it's hard to
convin that's just me it was really fun
it's a really great that's very smart
yeah it was really that's like the 80s
so they were innovating